from preventing crime to preventing
perhaps Boris Johnson from mounting a
political coup in the Conservative Party
he rallied at Conservative Party
conference this week to chuck checkers
and pursue a hard brexit Theresa May
responded by reminding Tories to place
country above ego wait what this has
never been about the country since the
referendum we have all been held hostage
to a civil war raging within the
Conservatives about Europe as all
generals like Cameron are slain new ones
like mrs. May and mr. Johnson compete
this was Boris's boldest bid yet for
power but the man is unfit to lead his
tactic is to either insult loads in his
crosshairs or make profoundly empty
statements of the sound because of his
gibberish more intelligent than they are
let's support the markets as the man who
recently said eff business he has
nothing of substance to contribute as he
proved when he was foreign secretary the
rest of us politically homeless are
faced with a choice in any future
general election between the devil and
the deep blue sea and that's just not
good enough
[Music]
now I do
I think Boris all right when you look at
the Conservative Party okay they've got
no they're a bunch of no marks basically
other departments do not I mean but the
one voice that comes out every time the
one person that's always in front of
that party Boris Johnson all right so in
terms of leader he's a natural leader
he's there he's at the front he's always
in the press he's always been talked
about he's always doing something right
so in a time when they're struggling for
leadership for me personally I think
he's the best he's the best one they
could take with the checkers and the
brexit and all the rest of it
you really me completely on there like
this he's in the public eye he's out
there he's outspoken he's standing up
for what he believes etcetera etcetera
etcetera okay that's all part of what
the public actually thinks of him so if
we have a look at these stats we see
that some actually interestingly that's
reason a polls currently ahead of Jeremy
Corbyn and so more people would
currently vote for Theresa may then call
them whereas if you look at Boris as
opposed to call be 50/50 and you know
I've got to say that within if you look
at the Tory Party voters within the
Conservatives Boris polls fill at the
highest everyone loves it what you've
got that within the party but with the
public he polls the highest in the
negative ratings at 57% of voters saying
they don't like him and that kind of
tells me that the Tory party and perhaps
Phil Campion are out of touch he's a
winner he's somebody who delivered the
believe referendum votes for the UK he
has a proven track record of achievement
he's won the City of London twice as
mayor he's the most popular MP in the
Conservative Party amongst the
conservative grassroots we need more
than ever
to have somebody in number 10 who has
popular support from the people and
Boris Johnson has that and who can win
for the Conservative Party Boris for me
I have no interest in hearing woman but
I am interested in here a lot Ruth
Davidson Esther says it let's have a
look at her what's interesting into
these coverage is he seems to be
spending an awful lot of time talking
about his London mayoral ship and very
little time in fact he's not even
mentioned the fact he was foreign
secretary for two years and was in the
room helping to influence this and
indeed was pretty Gators as you know
soon ago as December I can tell you
something else he's been spending a bit
of time doing who could miss a little
frolic in the wheat fields last week
didn't have time to talk about his time
as foreign secretary but he did have
time to remind us all and you know I'm
always finding myself inspired by Boris
Johnson he's such an inspirational
figure I just couldn't resist oh you do
you run a serious risk of encountering
something like this the Tory Party
conference couple of days ago has some
talks that was invite to do some talk
there and I did but I would say you
could taste the egos the second you
walked in you could just it was so I
found it such an extraordinary
experience and I think what's going on
in politics at the moment is terrible so
I am politically homeless I have know if
there was an election tomorrow I don't
even know what I would do last time I
was forced to sound myself because there
was no one for me to vote for and I
think what would I do now I think that
their Latin was down I think all of this
constant fighting and bickering
I think Boris Johnson is a PR
extraordinaire that's why is all over
the press all the time because he knows
what to say and how to say it and when
to say it and get the column inches as a
result I don't necessarily think that
makes you leadership material just
because you know how to be provocative
and controversial I wouldn't like to see
Boris Johnson as our next prime minister
what I would like to see is politicians
coming together
stopping their infighting and as best as
is possible
picking a decide on brexit for one of a
bear issue and coming together and
working collectively instead of fighting
and undermining I mean just before
Theresa May went on to do a talk someone
and I've got to be honest I didn't even
really know he was he's there and his
pitching is revert of no confidence and
his letter of no confidence to
tweezerman I'm thinking why what are you
doing like just support you might not
like her a bit of harmony for you
Michelle it's a shame that our Rachel's
not here this week but you know
exactly where she was have a look at
this what did you think Rachel because I
know you're a remainer well it was Chuck
checkers because the well the people did
not vote for checkers the people voted
to take back control and so technically
in his argument is that checkers doesn't
therefore it does not in accordance of
the will just and keep make a good
primary misspelled or C words perfect
absolutely perfect look at that that was
a splendid splendid splendid speech are
you proud of him of course I'm proud of
him not necessarily exactly what I've
heard Rachel saying when she's sitting
around this table but I'm just to kind
of bring in a serious note because I
think it actually is serious when we
talk about Boris potentially running the
country this is a tweet from our other
favorite Majid the Lord Mayor of
Sheffield and he says this which I agree
with Boris Johnson isn't funny Boris
isn't harmless Boris is a posh speaking
fancy dressed racist mop head imbecille
him being passively accepted as a benign
and reasonable potential leader of this
country genuinely makes me sick and any
smiles that's one of the races said
about Muslim women and also I just want
to pick up on a couple of things number
one Boris is nowhere near as popular as
he thinks he is as your poll suggests
but also you've got to look at his
numbers in terms of his victories in
London they were never that big so I
think he's actually deluded and if you
look at his owned constituency
he's lost half of his votes he's only
got a five five thousand can I just give
the floor to Boris for two seconds so
such a mistake of us two is such a
mistake of us to lead to leave on the
the checkers terms locked in the tractor
beam of Brussels in my fellow
conservatives this is not democracy that
is not what we voted for if he's a
constitutional outrage it's not taking
back control
it's forfeiting control and by the way
they know it in Brussels this is the
moment to chuck checkers
what big bold statement from Boris there
but where I will concede some ground
here right is that he doesn't need to
come up with solution himself a solution
that could be wrong I'm sure he's a man
too rolled out by the way but he's got
to come up with solution I think amber
Rudd summed out perfectly when she said
he's the life and soul of the party but
he's not the man you want driving new
home at the end of the evening and he's
fairly not really want running the
country